اذا فيما يخص المراقبه
سامحني على المقاطعه لكي الواضحين ايران
حل قدمت لك التزاما بانها ستسمح بتركيب
كافه معدات المراقبه التي كانت مركبه ضمن
الاتفاق النووي من ضمنها المراقبه عبر
الانترنت او برقم التخصيب وهل
ستدير ايران بيانات اجت المراقبه بشكل عام
اقول نعم ولكن ربما لاحظتم انه في البيان
المشترك
وهو مرجع لبعض
المسائل التي يجب ان يتم الاتفاق عليها
وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا لاننا
لم نتوقع ابدا
ان تكون قدرات المراقبه هذه ان تتاثر فيما
خصوص لغه عملها في السابق
فعلينا ان نناقش هذه المسائل
ولدينا افكارنا وستكون هذه جزء من
النقاشات الفنيه التي ستكون او ستجري
كمتابعه
لزياره
للبيان المشترك والفرق الفني سيسافر الى
ايران قريبا فلذلك اذا في احداث مشابهه
فيما يخص تحقيقات اتفاق الضمانعت
تقول اني راني عبرت عن جاهزيتها لتزويد
لكم بالمزيد من المعلومات ما مدى جديه
بهذا الالتزام
وذكرتم بعض الاشياء في المؤتمر الصحفي هل
انتم متاكدون منها
اماكن والاشخاص
وذكرتم بعض الاشخاص
وهم هو مجرد اتفاق لعقد اجتماع حولهم كما
قلت فيما خصوا معدات المراقبه هناك اجتماع
اخر
هل هناك التزام جاد بهذه المساله
كلا ليس اتفاق للمناقشه وللمساء نحن
نناقشهم الثلاثه اعوام فلسنا بحاجه الى
اتفاق لاستئناف المحادثات وناقشات الفكره
هي المضي قدما تجاهك كما قلت
لنتائج جديه وستشمل كل هذه المسائل اذا ما
سالتني
هل هنالك قائمه من الاماكن نعم قد تكون
هذه سريا كجزء من
التطبيق الضمانات الطبيعي بين اي دوله
وبين الوكاله وثانيا والى جانب هذا المبدا
فهنالك اشياء كثيره نتجاهلها لان هذا
مبداه التفاعل
او تفاعلنا معهم اذا ما زرنا مكانا واذا
ما اخذنا عينات بيئيه
من المواد او المعدات
فهذه ستؤدي الى مجموعه اخرى من الاجتماعات
وزياره اماكن اخرى فمن المستحيل افتراضيا
ان نحدد قائمه
مفصله بكل الاماكن او التواريخ
ذات الصلاه بهذه العمليه من صعبه جدا
التمييز بين
ما التزمت به رانو مع خبرتكم انها ستقدمه
لكم
وحقيقه الكثير من هذه الامور تعتمد على
اجتماعات مستقبليه هل هناك وضوح اضافي
نعم هنالك وضوح ولكن لماذا لا تسمح لنا
بيداء عملنا اما لم ترغب بالانضمامه الينا
كمفتش وقد يكون ذلك مثيرا
لما نحن نعرف كيف ستكون هنالك اماكن
وقوائم وربما بعض
الاجراءات المفيده وغير المفيده في هذه
الوكاله هنالك بعض اللحظات تظن العمليه
التي النقد فيها التقييمات وكما فعلنا
سابقا
احصل على اي شيء او لا نذهب الى اي مكان
في هذه العمليه بعد ذلك نرفعه تقريرا
ونشتكي ان صح التعبير
اعطونا بعض
او سامحونا اذا اقول انا استطيع اعطيكم
قائمه كامله بالتواريخ والاماكن والاشخاص
مستحيل ان يحصل هذا ابدا ليس هناك فقط بل
في اي
اتفاق او تحقيقات خاصه باجراءات الضمانات
الطبيعه الحساسه ولكن الوكاله
من اننا بحاجه الى بعض
الاجابات الجاده منهم حول مساله معينه
قدموا لنا بعضها كما تعرفون وبعد التقييم
ادركنا انها ليست ذات مصداقيه عاليه على
الصعيد الفني وهذه
الحلقه المفرغه الانطباعه وان هنالك فرصه
الان اننا نستطيع ان
نمضي قدما عندما كنت متاكدا ام لا يا
فرنسا لا ادري نحن نحاول نفعل نؤدي عملها
بافضل الشكل وانا متاكده مننا الحوار
سيستمر
اذا ما سمحت لي بسؤال المتابعه
هو ما الذي اختلف في هذه الزياره
حصل مرارا عنه اجتماع او زياره المجلس الى
طهران ما الذي اختلف الان
هنالك اختلافات كثيره
ولكن اولا هذه هي المره الاولى التي خذ
فيها حوارا جدا مع رئيس ايران
حول هذه الامور
او هذا له اهميه بالغه لانه بلا شك الرئيس
وتسنى
رؤيتي
وطريقه نرغب بها او بالعمل بها معهم كما
اخذنا حوارات مكثفه مع وزير الخارجيه
واحده من اكثر نقاشات
المستفيضه معهم
ومحد محمد اسلامي
وهو الشخص الذي يلتقيه بشكل مستمر ولكن
الى جانب ذلك وربما تقولنا بحوارات
ولكن
السياسات بشكل
التحدث مع اصحاب القرار يشكل فريقا كبيرا
بغض النظر عن النتائج التي توصل اليها
ولكن الى جانب كل ذلك وعندما ننظر الى
البيان
وحسب منطقه في المجالات الثلاثه
فلنرى نتائج حقيقيه في كافه هذه المجالات
فهنالك مثلا عندما تحدث عن فوردو حيث
الوكاله ستفتش تقريبا بين
او كل يوم واخر وهنالك
التزامات واتفاقات هامه جدا عندما اتحدث
عن
اليات مراقبه وتحقيقات اضافيه والفرقه
الفنيه تابع للوكاله سيسافر
عن قريب
لمراقبه هذه الخطوات ولذلك اعتقد بان
هنالك فرصه جيده
ولا عندما يقولون الشخص اين الوعود هذه
ليست وعود ولدينا بعض الاتفاقات الجاده
وفي نفس الوقت يجب ان اوديها عملي ولا
استسلم ابدا فانا استمر بعملي وبمحاولاتي
واربعون ان ازعجت بقدر اخر وربما الاكثر
انزعاجا عندما
نتواصل الى نتائج ربما اكون انا السبب
ولكن انا مستمعرون بالعمل واعتقد بان هذه
خطوه بالاتجاه المناسب لنعبر عنها بهذا
الشكل
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه يتحدث معكم بشكل
مباشر في بيان
تحت اي ظروف سيسمح لاسرائيل اي دوله اخرى
لمهاجمه
منشات التخصيب الايرانيه انت تسالني
نعم اطلعت
عليه
واود ان الخص شيئا لن اعلق بالتاكيد على
ما قاله اسرائيل عني او عن بياني ولكن
ساتحدث عن المساله بكل دقه لا يوجد اي شيء
جديد
حول ما قلته فقط كررت القانون الدولي
والقانون الدولي
من البروتوكولاته
وبعدها
العديد من قرارات المؤتمر العام لوكال
الدوليه طاقريه ومجلس المحافظين كلها كررت
ان الهجمات على منشات نوويه غير قانونيه
وانتهاك لمثاق المتحده
لذلك فانا لم اقل اي شيء يجب ان يعتبر على
انه خروج عن ما هو معروف بالطاقه العامه
لا باس ولكنني احببت اتابع على هذا السؤال
ما هي المخاطره التي تساعد لوكات الدوليه
بالتدخل عسكري في رمي غيري من اذا لم
تعالج كافه اسباب
الحلق هذه النسبه 84% لان هذا التكهنات
موجوده عند التسابيح
اولا فيما يخص نسبه 84%
وهذه مساله ربما
نقاش منفصل ولكن عندما يحاول البعض ان
يخلقوا الروابط بين التقارير او ما تقوم
به الوكاله او لا تقوم به وهذه الاحتمالات
من الاعمال العسكريه الامر الواضح هو انه
في كل منعطف وكل فرصه منذ ان
السلايم الدوله الذريه
دائما مفتوحه وابحث عن الامكانات
والاحتمالات والفرص واحاول ان اؤكد من ان
الحلو الدبلوماسيه الفنيه ممكنه هذا هو
عمل يا ربما العسكريين يخالفني الراي ولكن
بعد اربعين عام العمل في هذا المجال دائما
ساحاول فعل ذلك لذلك اعتقد بانه من الواضح
الوكاله هو عكس ذلك ونحن نحاول ان نوجد
المجالات ونبحث عن السبل التي تمكننا من
عملنا الاتفاقات او الوعود التي نستلمها
ربما تساعده
في الاستمرار بهذا الطريق
اللي
رادعي اي احتمال لاستخدام القوه
يعني كما قلت لا احب هذا الخيار
راقده بحثنا من العربيه
فيما يخص التحقيقات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه في ايران قلتم بان في هذه
الرحله وجدتم شيئا مختلفا واتفقتم على شيء
محدد اكثر اعرف انكم لا تحبون المواعين
ولكن لابد من
اتفقتم على الاطار عمل هل ستحل مساله
التحقيقات خلال اجتماعكم في يونيو ومتى
تتوقعون التوصل لنتائج
هذا الشيء
دائما نحاول ان نتعلم تجاربنا السابقه
واحدى الدروس التي تعلمتها هو انه ربما
وجود خارطه الطريق او التواريخ
او الرزنامه
ربما لا تستجيب الضروره الى الواجهه
الواقع الذي نواجهه
فالان نحن نركز على المشاكل بين ايدينا
وبلا شك نحن نعمل في خلفيه الواقع السياسي
وانا اعرف بانها لا يمكن ان تستمر هذه
العمليه
بالمضي بهذا الشكل البطيء الى الابد هذا
ما سالتيني اتمنى حلها في الاسبوع المقبل
ولكن بلا شك الامر سيستغرق الوقت وكما قلت
عندما اجبت عن الاسئله السابقه
لدينا ثلاثه مواقع ثلاثه مواقع مختلفه
بثلاث خصائص
فيما يخص وما نحاول التاكد منه فالعمليه
ستكون عمليه جديه ومنتظمه
انت والمجتمع الدولي أاعدكم باننا سنرضي
بكل سرعه في ذلك
مع رزنامه مجلس المحافظين لا اعرف اتمنى
ان يحصل ذلك وربما في وقت اسرع
موسى عاصيه الميادين تي في جدد
نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر الصحفي لرئيس
المدير العام وكاله الطاقه الذريه الدوليه
اننا نبحث عن السبل لردع اي احتمال
لاستخدام القوه النوويه العسكريا وان
القانون الدولي لا يسمح بالهجوم على منشات
نوويه ولم احصل على تعهدات من ايران لكنها
مناقشات جاده قال ايضا ان الاهم في الوقت
الراهن هو المضي قدما في عمليات المراقبه
في ايران وان وكاله الطاقه الذريه ستقدم
تقريرا دوريا بتطورات عمليه المراقبه في
ايران وان الفريق الفني لوكاله الطاقه
سيذهب الى طهران قريبا
ايضا اضافه جروسسي في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لسنا بحاجه الى اتفاق لاستئناف المناقشات
الفنيه مع ايران واننا نتطلع لبدء
المتابعه الفنيه في ايران في اسرع وقت
ممكن وان طهران وافقت على استئناف اجراءات
المراقبه كما قال رفع نعود الى الاستماع
الى ما يقوله رافائي
ل
دومينا
التي توقفت في شهر يونيو اعتقد انه بهذه
التدابير والترتيبات وفكره اعاده
ربط هذه الكاميرات والمعدات ربما سنتمكن
من ايجاد اجواء اكثر ايجابيه ربما تفضي في
نهايه المطافي الاستئناف المفاوضات
نعم تفضل
اتساءل فيما اذا كنت تشعر ربما بخيبه
الامل بشان ما قيل في ايران منذ نهايه
زيارتك قبل او بعد بضع ساعات من وصولك الى
عقدت مؤتمر صحفي في المطار يبدو ان
السلطات الارني تراجعت عن بعض الوعود التي
قدمتها لكم مثل الوصول الى الافراد قالوا
انه لن يسمح بالاتصال باي اشخاص وبالنسبه
للمواقع غير المعننه الثلاثه قالوا انها
او انهم
يعيدون بانهم سيتعاونوا كما جرى من قبل مع
الوكاله وهذا ما تم طيله اربع سنوات فيما
يخص الوعود كما هم يعيدون ايضا بانكم
سوف تحصلون على المزيد من الفرص
لعمليه المراقبه وتحقق هل انت مصاب بخيبه
امل او هل انت
مفرد في التفاؤل فيما انجزته
لا هذا ولا ذاك لست لم اصبي خيبه امل اقرا
واراء ما يقال
في هذه العمليه لو كان لي ان
استرشد
بتصريحات الصحفيه
لن اذهب بعيدا نعم صحيح هذه تصريحات صحيح
وانا اتصل بهم مباشره ولا اتحدث اليهم عبر
وسائل الاعلام استمع اليهم وهناك سياقات
سياسيه يتم فيها التصريح بامور عديده تقول
لي بانهم لن يقوموا بامر ما سوف انظر في
الامر
بالجديه التي يتطلبها الامر انا لم اصاب
بخيبه الامل طبعا هذه بدايه مرحله جديده
ليست بعمليه جديده بعد الاتفاقات التي
استطعنا التوصل اليها انا لست مفرطا في
تفاؤل حتى انا لست متفائل اريد ان اكون
واقعيا ادرك ان هذه هي الامور تكتسب اهميه
وحاولت ان احصل على هذه النتائج اذا بمعنى
راض بانه لاننا يبدو اننا نمضي باتجاه
ارضيه اكثر صلابه وان بعض الامور سوف تنجز
ونقطه نقطه مساله مساله
اذا ما سمحت لي لدي سؤالا
حل اتفقتم مع الايرانيين ان الوكاله
الدوليه سيسمح لها بالدخول الى
البيانات المسجله مسبقا
ما هو وضع الكاميرات التي يستخدم مره اخرى
في المستقبل ام لم تتفق على ذلكم
الايرانيين هذا السؤال الاول والثاني
اذا لاي سبب كان هنالك زياده كبيره في
التخصيب في ايران واكثر
ما مدى
سرعه
كم سيستغرق الامر لمفتشكم اولا في جوابي
لفرنسوه اعتقد بان اجبت عن السؤال الاول
هنالك بعض المسائل المحدده التي يجب ان
نوضحها علينا ان نتذكر اننا ربما بدانا
بخوض في الكثير من التفاصيل
وللعامه لا اعرف ان كان ذلك واضحا ولكن
في الاتفاق السابق حول هذه المعلومات
اليه محدده انهم يحتفظون بالمعلومات وانه
تكون تحت ختم الوكاله الدوليه فهذه مساله
علينا الاجتماعهم لمناقشتها هذا ما
استمرينا بنفس المنطق او اذا كانت هنالك
اي تعديلات على هذا المنطقه والاتفاق وهذه
مساله فنيه هذا اولا
فيما يخص الزياده ان حصلت زياده الكبيره
اولا استطيع ان نقول من اننا قادرون الى
تحديد والتعرف على هذه المسائل من دون
زياده بشكل عام الوكاله الدوليه ستكون
قادره
على التعرف على اي نوع من المستويات
اذا كانت زياده او انخفاض في اي وقت
هذه مهمه وحكم عليها من قبل المفتشين على
انها ماساله في غايه الاهميه نظرا
لاساليب العمل وكذلك التعديلات
التي اجريت على هذا هذه المنطقه من
المنشاه
والوظائف التي تسمح بها فالشعر انه سيكون
المهم جدا ان يكون هنالك تواجد
اطول او هذا لا يعني اننا من دونها نستطيع
التواصل اليها حتى من دونها نستطيع الحصول
على اي قراءات لها اهميه تماما كما كان
الحل من قبل